major key alert right here chicken I saw
your watch hey what's going on everybody
for first we feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones the show with
hot questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Joey Fatone yeah he
plays Angelo and My Big Fat Greek
Wedding - that's right he's a shot gun
wielding Sheriff blowing off zombies
heads dead seven welcome to the show
thank you sir I've seen much about this
and heard so much about this are you
excited I'm ignited I'm a little nervous
and then I also my eyes are a little bit
tearing a little bit chief it just
seemed from smelling some of it and we
have to acknowledge it Joey's coming off
a cleanse and we're going naked chicken
tenders yeah I was gonna do that I was
gonna do the naked wings of it I'm
literally going up a cleanse and I could
add chicken now first was fruits and
vegetables so I can do this now but I
don't even know what it's gonna do to my
stomach as far as a sauce and so it's
gonna be fun it might not be fun guys
get it going
all right man you ready for this first
one sure we're going with sriracha so
not that bad
I've every throw I like it and your food
guy I like when food guys on the ship
with Bowie you fo you put a lot of
epital also watch in there so you were
quoted once the saying you have an iron
stomach
I do yeah so we don't lied we'll see you
went to dr. Phillips High School in
Orlando I did and I'm sure you know this
but I was a pretty surprised to learn
how many famous alumni that school had
in just this like four to five year
window and I want to make sure I get
everybody because yours you if you have
any long mm-hmm AJ Pierzynski yes
Wayne Brady correct uh Johnny Damon yeah
and then dj khaled did you kill it was
in the same user yeah already was here
yeah heard he was on here he only got to
two or three yes what it was all these
guys walk in the halls at the same time
yeah I wonder did you guys ever cross
paths are you friends with anybody have
another J AJ Pierzynski was in was in my
class was in one of my classes calibers
and was in I think two of my classes or
one of my classes as well you had two
classes with DJ Khaled was DJ
interrupting AP Calculus with somebody
Tommy what's even buddy about Khalid is
people like look like all he's from the
hoodies from this his family old a store
called merry-go-round on the floor Amal
I mean he had nothing he was rich but he
had money
I don't know everybody know DJ Kali Jai
Kell I'm like I also teach it on my
conscience I know the kid from high
school and his name was Khaled Khaled
yeah
which is interesting tough to go through
high
alright ready for number two sure
alright so this one is Tapatio again not
all that actually deal yeah that's a big
so about a year ago above-average
published this open letter from Joey
Fatone now it wasn't actually by Joey
Fatone no but as is often the case with
satirical articles online everybody
thought knew that it was written by Joey
Fatone and there were some shots at one
direction and I don't know what it's
like to be on the receiving end of a One
Direction fan wrath oh but I imagine
that they're ruthless and that it was
always funny is it was more I did
something one time where I said it was
the HuffPost or whatever and I said
something about that
she's saying they're going on to work as
they needed the money I got reamed cuz
I'm friends with Nick and I'm friends
with all those guys I got reamed to no
end by them more than I did with the
work
One Direction bands like way more so the
Backstreet Boys fans even that many
overs it was a big few elements
oh you suck you're an ass dissing a pup
a blob oh it was crazy ready for number
three yes all right so this one is al
Yucatec Oh kriby and habanero
so this is where Khalid got to and then
bailed out basically yeah I mean
whatever sriracha right thinking what
season in that season we might have been
just doing like Texas Pete's really and
he was like it was a blown-out sweating
it was like the saddest most pathetic
thing you've done a handful of cooking
shows you did my family recipe rocks you
did guy versus Rachael celebrity
hook-ups
you hosted one of my favorites rewrapped
and I'm wonder with rewrapped when you
guys take on a Twinkie and you have the
chef's that have to reinvent the Twinkie
right do you find that let's say five
chefs make their version of a Twinkie
are all five of those Twinkies better
than an actual Twinkie are they all
worse than an actual tweak one that they
made the one that they love in other
words can you beat the classics yeah I
don't you know you can never beat the
classics cuz it's just that it's that
taste it's that whole thing I think a
lot of times - it's not handmade it's
made by machine in a sense so everything
is precise and it's always gonna have
that same quality taste are you aware
that there's a whole corner of the
internet that thinks that you and Guy
Fieri are doppelganger we've done a
couple shows together we first met
actually uh in Kentucky Derby a couple
years every time the horse races we go
and the first thing every committee
knows is one person calls me Joey for
telling I wanna kick their ass for my
listen anybody calls me guy for Yeti
i'ma come on look at you I mean come on
really
nobody really I don't even die I mean I
dyed my hair but not my frickin goatee I
don't die that but he we headed off
great he's such a great guy and that's
actually how I got guy versus Rachel we
were talking it's getting now I just do
when you breathe in you're not on the
cleanse anymore no it's it's gonna be a
client's later on that's what you have
all black it'll just splatters all over
the place number four right pain is good
louisiana-style
pain is that's what it's cold good
that's what's called pain is good it
says medium it's not hot
it was easy to constipated or screaming
I had TJ Miller on the show and I asked
him this question but he was kind of
mean about it
stop doing this show so I want to redo
it okay I'm kind of using this job as a
way to workshop my career and obviously
things could be better right and I
admire you because you've hosted so many
shows and I'm wondering if you have
maybe some advice for us or me
personally on ways we can make this
thing a little bit better because we can
take just don't suck be honest that's
the fun part you know and don't I think
a lot of people try to be cheesy about
[ __ ] and I think that's what's cool
about you is you actually you give it
straightforward I mean I've I've watched
you in so you're straightforward honest
and and I think from the first interview
when somebody does that it's you got to
figure and sense them out a lot of
people how people do interviews you can
sense them out a lot and see what
they're feeling how would you have open
the show would you have done something
different like Oh more energy but the
thing is is but that's your style not
you and that's what makes you you
because everybody's like hey how's it
going hey not me not you all right so
number five Joey you've come on a
historic day I want everybody to know
some excited we're moving on up hot ones
now held up its own hot sauce it's made
by our boys homeboys hot sauces out of
Phoenix they're great and then we're
gonna sell it at Heat inist
that's in Brooklyn you can buy it online
hot ones it's got a fiery chipotle base
I'm not lying
it is the best damn hot sauce ever made
and Joey if this sucks
I'll tell you that so I'm sorry to
interrupt if it's good let us know this
is it right here and this is the hot
ones hot sauce pick it up smell it
a little pineapple cut yeah I'm actually
pretty damn good and then it catch like
it doesn't show up a little bit but not
so much right exactly like with hot ones
were like let's not make the world's
hottest sauce you know everyone's trying
to do that let's just make it why the
best hot sauce ever
I think we made yeah it's not obscure I
can see that like going especially on
chicken but like shrimp and stuff like
that could be awesome dead seven I think
it's gonna be a hundred times even more
talked about than sharknado because the
cast is this amazing sort of boy band
reunion right and I know that you're
friends with a lot of these guys but
sometimes I wonder in the same way that
former NBA players get together and
instantly bond right guys who are
astronauts get together and they rightly
bond because they have this extremely
unique world perspective that no one
else has sure so I wonder when you're
just kickin it with Nick Carter and Jeff
Timmons and it's between scenes what do
you guys talk about what sorts of things
do you mean anything and everything uh
the most time we had actually was a lot
of fun it was it was Nick was really
busy a lot he was doing he was starting
to get Goering directing to up towards
for dance with the Stars so it was me
Eric from from o-town Jeff and AJ and
Howie really hung out and the cool thing
about them is we both we all have Hannah
had stories there was o-town with guy
Eric from oh Tom from Oh Tom backstreet
and us we all kind of grew up in the
same area in a sense but it was
hilarious of the stories of like how was
the first thing he said to me is like
how did you guys really get together
because I didn't really know and
understand the whole process and how
this happened and once that took off we
started asking out that we started
asking okay well how did this happen
with this and you know you thanks to
them they were supposed to do this
Disney Channel show that we picked up
doing and we ended up doing it and
actually I think that's when it really
skyrocketed our career really started us
so every time I dangled my how I thank
you very much I appreciate you say no to
that cuz it up is out
all right ready for number six yes so on
this one rogue we're going wrong it is
Laura blood orange scorpion pepper sauce
yes hi River rogue
so you finish runner-up and season for
Dancing with the Stars and from what I
understand about that show is it's like
a full-time job where you're just
basically in the gym from sunup to
sundown working your ass off that whole
time
well yeah you you put whatever you put
into it you get out of it in a sense I
worked I did four or five hours a day
every day and yeah the sneaks up on you
it's starting to go look yeah and when
you do a show like that that is that
much of a commitment there's how bad how
bad does it suck then to finish second
because like I almost feel like it's
doing this show and doing nine wings
like I'd almost rather do zero you know
what's even funnier I actually liked it
that I did it after I made it to the top
three I was happy I really was genuinely
like of course I want to [ __ ] win but
I was generally happy ago you know what
I made it this far you can't go any
further
cuz it's the finale it's the three
people lash a dance-off you get kicked
off or you win that's it so I was like
alright I made it this far and it's so
funny because after that I got a lot of
jobs from that because people saw my
personality didn't see me just as a
person from instinct so they saw me you
realize I like hot Indian food so this
is okay just like very impressed so far
you got a set handling this much better
than our average guest oh that's for
sure they're a bunch of vagina sorry
Kelly Talon major key alert right here
chicken hearts off your watch
congratulations you played yourself
alright number seven which is excuse me
pain 100% together and then this one we
have an ebay roundup we found a bunch of
strange NSYNC memorabilia items on eBay
and so I'm wondering if we can just show
you a handful and you can sort of react
to him first
uh we have the suit jacket that your
friend Lance wore on the cover of
Rolling Stone $2,200 I never wore a
dress on either seized money no I've
seen it of course I was there but it's
funny I think that they have yeah I
never I never knew they're selling it
for 2,200 bucks oh it's going to charity
we have a full set Oh full marionettes
and could find those at 300 bucks 300
bucks sweet I got a bunch of sets I'll
sell for $300 you can make yeah you can
prai's Joey right the ones that are
cooled out with the real marionettes we
actually had real full-size marionettes
like it was like no joke that was the
first idea that we had it that's why and
then these became toys because it was
not affordable for young kids are you
dreading this cuz you haven't eaten yet
uh okay here we go we have a JT sign
Fedora 239 bucks
no Laura I got a bun Chee's I didn't
tell me don't cheap I give you the five
bucks this is a pretty cool item it's an
Afghan blanket with the whole squash
it's just we I've seen this but I've
never seen it in person 50 bucks
uh-huh I would look at the faces I kind
of weird-looking to like get the eyes
right how about this one this one I'm
sure you've seen this is a poster you
I've seen this yes is when I had a weird
twisty thing and then that the Superman
symbol was funny ask you about the
Superman upgraded it later on meaning it
had diamonds around it and then I got
rubies and more diamonds added to it the
same charm I still have it
flex wears like how that's getting there
uh in a safety deposit box yeah little
bit not much but it's getting there I
would say though of all the people we've
had in here the most impressive
performances in my opinion have been
Coolio Who am I basically unfazed until
I dumped half this bottle out on the
last wing just to show off and ended up
like he might be dead right and then um
another Miami rapper gunplay was in here
and he was just killing the whole set
but you're right up there with those
three I'm Tony right I can feel it don't
worry I'll let you know if it R it's
really that bad now I'll kill myself on
up so this one is the bomb 24 times
hotter than a jalapeno I can't believe
I'll do it this is the stupidest thing
ever we've got Michelle yep but it's
great so on paper being in a group like
NSYNC sounds like heaven on earth but
no matter the group there always seems
to be a little it seems to be some
discontent you know it doesn't matter
the group this is not an NSYNC specific
right there always seems to be which
makes me wonder like what is the worst
thing about being young and famous and
having the world by the balls um being
frivolous and stupid with with your
money and what your power and thank God
that we've never had that moment in a
sense oh yeah uh that's why it's so hard
because you're focused on that you can't
even answer the damn questions rom what
we said what would be like the worst
thing like everybody no you know
whatever no but we all keep our
ourselves in check I think the worst day
ever just in general is is the constant
man
the constant um but that came to talk
yeah that was good ah the repet the
repetition of everything and you get you
just get tired and get fed up with it
it's a vicious cycle because we'll go on
tour we'll go out there say for instance
three o'clock we you know start
soundcheck of whatever we do so we get
there at noon we start soundcheck get
there noon do the whole thing meet
people do interviews get done do the
show at seven o'clock or eight or
whatever we get done around maybe 11:00
11:30 get on the bus and drive to the
next city
and do it over and over over again when
that's done then we do the videos when
we work rerecord stuff that one just
bites your ass Wow
so number nine Mad Dog 357 never a
pleasurable one yeah okay I would now go
why is all that I would not try to clean
this one so to go along with that
you see the bite seriously do you all
see the whole wussy bike he just took it
to it about joey fatone snitch how many
times you do it so many times look it's
gonna hurt I'm not denying it all right
if I just turned their head away when I
took a bite out cuz they know what's
happening but then going along with that
like what was your mindset like with the
day that NSYNC stopped were you upset
were you sad were you relieved like what
was your like Oh fiery burning right now
um was it a more painful day than today
yes you know it was sad at first but it
was it was a good thing that that
happened what happens why does that
happen when you start talking she's like
it's like time-release Meow's um yeah I
mean it was like it one of those things
but I was like you know what now I got a
chance to do whatever I always wanted to
do and I did Broadway I did rent which
was fun which was a blast you know I had
such a great time doing it and to be
able to do other things and open up all
the doors for me was great all right
last one
does it ever get old it is old it is old
this show is old well I think is old but
it's like a new thing everything Wow a
new experience it's a little it's always
the same experience but it's always a
shitty experience right last one kind of
feelings gonna go grab the last wing
what's that you do wow that's one uh-huh
yeah okay
good drops right there here we go
as we talked about earlier very
impressive that you were able to get
through that whole era without having a
bigot beefs without having any big beefs
with 98 degrees or Backstreet Boys or
O'Town or any of those guys right but
one guy who went after you guys kind of
hard is mm and he went after Chris
Kirkpatrick personally mr. catch me you
can get to action what's in the movie
and I've always wondered have you ever
met him you ever talk to him oh if so
what was that like if you haven't met
him did you guys ever get together and
we're like whoa what the hell is this
guy's problem with us we met him he's
always like so never said anything
really I think Chris I have talked to
him oh man yeah that now I know why the
questions cuz when you breathe and talk
out it kills Chris talked em in him I
think he did and you know is all it's
all know it's all persona it's all about
having that fun with that I don't think
you really like meant it like he does
show you guys on a red carpet i guy I
was like I got some stuff I gotta get
off my chest
he wasn't like me he was just writing
stuff I'm taking this water-tight a cold
today drink two or three hundred yeah
that one's you but we have reserves did
our Chris oh look how many sips of milk
gum tape there in like three cups of
water what about Chris what was he
thinking at that time no get he got job
I thought was Dave was on it I love it
what were you thinking when he wasn't
doing all that stuff just he's making
music or what yeah whatever arrives with
ass kicked
Chris Kopec trick we're gonna get your
ass I guess until later he came up with
it is like it is a good line it does
flow ah all right Joey Fatone yes sir
heavyweight champ coming in clear oh my
god he'll dumb the floor is yours you
got 30 seconds tell the people to see
you're here he's wherever you want the
floor is yours man go see my big fat
greek wedding - it's hotter than this uh
and then also oh my god my eyes are
tearing dead 7 April first on Syfy it's
gonna be fun gonna be awesome gonna be
good time just like this
was amazing and you'll enjoy it good see
it Bossier woo was always big fan of the
Elevens yeah uh you know any thought
about being smart got to be quick sorry
we don't know I don't want you to that's
why I do it
I don't know we on the pieces just on it
to get me to the level where he said
opener on the floor that makes it floor